le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
depuis 13 ans à l'occasion de la journée
de la femme le conseil départemental
organise le prix célimène l'occasion
pour les femmes artistes amateurs de
s'exprimer dans les domaines de la
sculpture la photographie et la peinture
animé guen a reçu le premier prix de
l'édition célimène 2016 pour sa peinture
repos cette enseignante dont la toile a
été acheté par l'artothèque de saint
denis
pinte encore quotidiennement chez elle
depuis son domicile à saint gilles
[Musique]
au chrs jaune bleu outremer rouge carmin
si ces couleurs ne vous disent rien
pour anne ce sont autant de nuances qui
lui permettent de donner vie à ses
oeuvres
je suis en train de préparer ma peinture
avec mon médium et puis mes pinceaux
pour commencer à travailler
visage il ne se passe pas une journée
sans que la saint gilloise ne s'installe
à l'ombre de sa varangue pour peindre
depuis toute petite j'ai toujours aimé
peindre dessiner j'ai toujours mais bon
c'était surtout les petits croquis sur
des feuilles et puis j'ai pris des cours
avec un professeur qui m'a aubin
communiquer toutes ces techniques de
peinture parce que c'est aussi de la
technique
je cherche à faire une couleur très très
sombres justement je mélange de l'orangé
de mars et du bleu outremer
c'est beaucoup plus nuancé on peut aller
du plus foncé au plus clair d'un certain
etc
à base pour pour mon visage son modèle
pour cette toile une photo d'archivé
trouver sur internet
retravailler avec une touche plus
personnelle c'est un projet que j'ai
avec une amie qui montrent un lausanne
ces combats et elle voulait peindre la
femme malgache
elle voulait des photos de femmes
malgaches mais détourné avec une pointe
d'humour avec l'aspect un peu plus
contemporain à l'intérieur de sa maison
l'étoile recouvrent les murs chacune
d'entre elles a sa propre histoire
alors qu'elle est une ville elle voilà
j'ai exposé à les tâches de tableau que
j'ai fait en rapport avec l'inde
je réveille dalayman je rêve toujours et
je paie ni beaucoup sur ce sujet afin de
sortir ses oeuvres de la sphère intime
et les soumettre au regard d'autrui
anne s'est inscrite au prix célimène
2016 pari réussi puisque elle a remporté
le premier prix pour sa peinture repos
le tableau qui est qui a remporté le
prix
racheté par l'artothèque partie du
patrimoine culturel réunionnais et ça
c'est une vraie récompense parce que je
suis arrivé à la réunion j'avais 7 ans
ça a été tout de suite eu un coup de
fouet ce prix qui permettent également à
l'enseignante de s'assumer en tant qu
artiste à part entière
ça m'a encouragé à continuer et puis ça
m'a donné confiance en moi lorsque je
peins mon geste est plus sûr il n'ya
plus je suis moins dans le doute je
j'arrive
j'arrive vraiment à peindre de manière
plus détaché ce à libérer ma peinture
cette reconnaissance du public ainsi que
du jury encourage également à se lancer
dans des nouveaux projets tu aimerais
bien aussi travailler en collaboration
avec un écrivain réunionnais ou
[Musique]
un écrivain qui fait des albums pour
enfants mais en rapport avec la réunion
et en est l'illustratrice al'approche de
l'édition 2010 est du prix célimène le
département souhaite perpétuer cette
tradition en encourageant les femmes à
partager leurs talents et si l'édition
du prix seligmann connaît un succès
grandissant d'année en année c'est que
il ya véritablement a besoin pour les
femmes de parler des de s'exprimer à
travers la généralement le monde
artistique n'est pas aussi facile
d'accès qu'on le croit et c'est aussi un
moyen de donner de la reconnaissance à
ce travail de faire connaître des
artistes de permettre à ces artistes pas
seulement d'avoir un prix mais de
rencontrer aussi des artistes
professionnels pour prendre échanger et
pour ouvrir au plus grand nombre
l'expression de chacun et de chacune et
dans le cadre de la journée de la femme
je crois que nous faisons oeuvre utile
et communicative
[Musique]
chaque année à l'occasion de la journée
de la femme le conseil départemental
organise le prix célimène il est
accessible à toutes les femmes de plus
de 18 ans résidant à la réunion n'ayant
jamais participé à une exposition et
n'ayant pas bénéficié de formation
artistique le département attribuera
plusieurs prix suite à la sélection du
jury selon les modalités suivantes le
premier prix ou prix célimène 2017 sera
récompensé de 3000 euros le second prix
de 2000 euros le troisième prix de 1500
euros et enfin le quatrième prix ou prix
coup de coeur du jury percevra 1000
euros les dossiers d'inscription peuvent
être retirés à l'adresse suivante 39 bis
rue du général de gaulle 97400 saint
denis ou à télécharger sur le site du
département www.cn.ca 4 point fr
[Musique]
m